[Music]
I'm gonna try story mode because this
game has one of those and I I'm gonna
try it and also thank you to gung-ho for
sponsoring this video
downloading in Jolla today for free oh
yeah here we go and apparently this is
story mode look at that cat oh my god
that is adorable
that is really adorable alright defeat
the space ninja Oh is training time okay
it worked guys it worked guys now
everyone hush your faces okay it's
training time
yo grabs sure
yeah Gramps van I told you to call me
master this is just the only voice in
this game oh yeah
Master I've been wondering about what
exactly we ninja do we'd beat a bad guys
right like in the movies and comics Oh
putting it most simply my bro
I suppose that is true but our foes are
not limited to just bad guys animals and
plants they too can also be ninja one of
both the good and bad for plants
huh so we just take out the bad ones
right all right then worse leave it to
me Master Gramps why does he never
listen until the end oh well I'm gonna
play the game all right I max all right
I can't jump I'm very bad hi go away
okay so I've got the whole died do it
master there was some kind of weird
nasty looking creature out there that my
boy was a space ninja it's kind of an
extraterrestrial life-form like an alien
you never told me I'm done with that you
never told me there be aliens why would
these nasty aliens come to earth the
answer to that my dear boy is that I
have no idea the legend goes a meteor
fell from outer space how is it
connected to the power of shinobi no one
can say perhaps the ninja arts have some
deep connection to outer space the power
of the shinobi learning more about this
is a vital ninja mission okay
well looks like it's time to continue
your training okay Oh what okay the
whole switching thing I got a hold back
on doing that ultimate street sign all
right I was a street sign is that
painful I imagine that would be horrific
Lee painful I imagine that would be
horrendously painful Sarah way to change
it to the audit behind a sign so a way
to change it to the auto turning camera
because I don't think I'm gonna be very
good at that unless I need to just get
good which is probably true all right
goodbye
you know these don't actually look like
space ninjas they look like slimes with
masks which they are hey master so
what's the deal with this gum anyway
there's a great invention that harnesses
ninja DNA what this is ninja gum why
don't we chewing
ninja gum contains elements that awakens
the ninja powers within you this
includes new ways to battle the ability
to throw gum shuriken or to attack and
move like for running away a good
strategist must know when to retreat as
well as when to fight well that sounds
simple enough
and let's put the theory into practice
first you must yadda yadda all right
here we go listen to the end I keep
telling you all right I'm a sign I am
incredible at this I think I think sure
I did it oh hey buds I'm a sign
what was that what sampler yeah what is
the parry thing I know that these are
all skills that I've master can I take a
break can i play I'm pooped
they just keep coming don't they this is
why we need more and more ninja with DNA
like yours so my dad - quite so your
father was part of an elite group of
ninja called the Oni wolf on shoot so he
fought against those space ninja -
indeed
you never know when or where a space
ninja might show up to that end wna
recruited ninja from all over the world
to protect the ninja arts and the power
of shinobi ninjalah was created as part
of wnas training program I know that we
blow bubbles and do all this cool stuff
right now you're starting to understand
I'm very lost very unclear all I know
oh that's interesting what am i
witnessing oh no no no no no no no no no
kill it kill it kill it kill it
craft yourself a bigger weapon okay I
don't like it I don't like its feet I
don't like it's a hands oh I'm in
trouble all right I don't like anything
about it hey buds
all right goodbye buds later buds
see you around buds more buds how about
one of the EES master we're not done yet
we've just been getting warmed up so far
no no I don't want it I don't want it
but now it seems to be time for the main
event
awful horrible everything about it is
terrible that thing no I don't think I
can handle it
recall all I've taught you and victory
will be yours do I have to if you
succeed a great reward awaits you I like
reward all right here we go
what's wrong no thank you I don't want
any of that oh no no okay
dumb face near stupid feet why do you
have toes why do you have toes go around
that's pretty easy and done to make it
explode uh-huh master Gramps what was
that I thought I was done for if you're
troubled by the likes of that what
you're saying there are even tougher
enemies oh no where are you going I
think I'll be going home now great but
come on wait hey Gordon
I've not long left for this world your
father was a brave ninja he had to make
many sacrifices
since ancient times ninja have done
their duty from the shadows duty don't
make a poop joke your father's blood
runs strong in you my father's blood Wow
carry on is duty you must enter ninja
line gross
I all rise to the top of ninjalah you
will have many rivals do not neglect
your training train hard and become
stronger I don't like that what am I
looking at I hate it I hate everything
about it I hate it destroy it burn it
no I don't want to do be continued I
don't want any of that all right
all of my skills that I've learned will
definitely serve me in this upcoming
battle I'll try the yo-yo I don't know
if these are actually any good or
anything but I like the donut so I will
go with the donut of a donut kind of guy
okay so donut interesting you kick it
that's not what I would have suspected
that donut do okay that's a big overhead
spike Oh interesting so you can chip
dunked on you I guess is there must be
like combos that I'm not aware of for
every weapon I'm Naruto running oh here
we go
okay I guess I'm good enough I will do
my father's blood proud okay here we go
I'm so ready for this and by this I mean
I'm running away I'm running away from
my responsible hey buds yeah take that
okay and they ran away too
wha-what-what is hitting me I don't know
what's happening what what am i doing
I have no idea what I'm doing oh my god
I'm not able to do anything do old
donked I don't know what I did but I
sure did it oh where am i I can't even
see I don't know what I did but I dunked
my way to fifth place that's how I do
everybody in case you're wondering no
you're being an opportunist and I don't
like it I'm a dunk on this guy and you
are going to I don't know what I just
did
they're confused I got someone I think
oh I do I'm doing it go away everybody
Julie no I don't understand get dunked I
guess oh my goodness
I haven't III have no idea what my
buttons are doing but I'm in second I
must be incredible the like the legends
are true
I was always donut alright I'll take it
how do I do the dunk thing oh that's not
good
I don't know what I did but I died sure
did it
[Music]
who do I have okay
I did it by dunked oh oh I was second
[Music]
okay that's fine okay that's fine I did
it I'm top three
I'm not crying you're crying why are you
crying
stealing my look too and I don't like
that I did it I always knew I could I
always knew I had it in me
I always suspected that I secretly had
ninja DNA coursing through my blood that
I could get the chaos the cools the it
ponds I knew that the gum was in my soul
and you knew it too if you believed in
me thank you thank you I'm amazing
but I'm incredible I'm outstanding I
deserve this
I deserve it I'm very unsure of how to
do the dunk thing but the dump thing is
cool like I like the dunk the dunks rad
BAM and then the web it's cool I just
wish I knew how I'm pushing as many
buttons in as many ways as I possibly
can but at the end of the day I'm just
grasping for straws I don't know which
ways up half the time okay stand by dojo
it is it's bizarre like of the controls
are simple and yet not simple okay
that's over hand and then what did I
just do
I don't know how oh I did it again what
am i doing to do that what am i doing to
do the dunk it's so cool but how I think
is it down oh my god it is interesting
it's down but then they need to be up to
actually get hit by it I think so they
got to be in the right spot for it but
if I get it it's really cool there's a
surprising amount of depth in this game
that I thought it was just like a button
masher but apparently there's a little
bit more dunk alright we're going in
alright this is gonna be the one all
right let's do this let's do this let's
do this let's do this yeah let's do this
I'm ready I'm ready I'm so ready I'm not
ready I am unready oh no that's not what
I wanted
too early on the dunk oh my god again
interesting oh my god it's the dumps the
dunks do it baby
Duncan dunk
alright never mind carry on thank you
take care dunked
oh but it didn't it didn't get him oh my
goodness
okay maybe oh I'm dead what I'm dead
[Music]
oh well how am i I'm trying I think I am
all that did nothing grabbed it yeah
baby
oh my god oh my god this is nuts oh ah
come here you you come here come here
you you come here come here you and get
you know yeah I got the guilt I got it
oh my god
give me that whoa hey cyan welcome to
the party I guess dunked on nothing up
chunk tear oh hello can i oh hey how are
you doing there bud
oh my goodness I'm very lightning oh no
not me why would you do this to me I
don't want to dunk air I am gonna die
I'm gonna die
I got oh my god I got him I locked him
up holy crap I did it okay so it's like
I it's like a one-two punch kind of oh
no no no not like this oh please let me
just uh I would like to take you for a
ride oh no I would like to take someone
free right I'm taking someone for a ride
oh my god oh my god Oh God
there I go that's me then no I wanted to
craft the big weapon no I wanted to
craft the big weapon oh no I want to
steal a kill oh yes
damn damn damn no oh I was about to say
please don't ah but I got so many poems
all right you know what I'll take that I
I actually started to get it I actually
started to understand I started to get
the combos I started to learn how to get
to dunk on people I was getting it I was
getting it it was becoming more than
just button mashing there is a
surprising amount of complexity to that
that is gonna do it for me with nan
Jolla for today yes I am sponsored by
nan Jolla which means they are paying
for this video but here's my honest
opinion they don't pay me to say it's
amazing this was a lot of fun like
legitimately it was a lot of fun I
enjoyed it and I wouldn't say that if I
didn't actually have fun with it it's a
bit chaotic at first it's difficult to
like understand what's going on but when
you get it and when you are actually
able to play and you're actually able to
understand how the moves work because
button mashing was actually working
against me there's kind of like a
chaining of actions that like continue
one after another and you have to be
aware of where you are and what's
happening to be able to do it right so
it is fun it's also free so if you have
a Nintendo switch check it out for
yourself
thank you everybody so much for watching
and just remember don't spill the beans
that would go very poorly for all of you
so thank you thank you take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
and as always
I will see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]